[Musique]
moi je veux un week end à marrakech
toutes les semaines il ya des ânes
partout tout le monde sait ce que tu
fais à marrakech mon gars je ne dirais
pas devant une caméra mois et voilà pour
le bonus les chevaux c'est des purs soir
à cenon
alors pourquoi tu es juif et le gaulois
qui l'ont d'abord moi moi moi quand
j'entends week end à marrakech et des
syndicats si tu fous mon seul quoi
qu'est ce que je fous pourquoi je sais
moi alors la momie 3 mai mais tu fout
quoi le melon celui les premiers partout
et prom nigéria la palestine en france à
nanterre oui oui et toi t'es quoi
oui oh [ __ ] c'est super tu me permets
de toquer à les it ok tu me permet de
regarder qui s'est sorti non l'olympia
de londres est tranquille et on sort ce
soir à salta on s'emmerde pour rester là
non vous êtes vraiment des fils de
couper le jeûne 2008 musique pourquoi
deux manches physique est au point mort
depuis deux ans on essaie lancer des
projets artistiquement très ambitieux ça
c'est de la merde ça peut cartonner
si dans moins de six mois monsieur
musique n'a pas rempli le lapi avec un
nouvel artiste
il cédera sa place de directeur et
beaucoup vous fais pas ça un prêtre et
un email
réunis sur scène pour chanter ensemble
non mais je rigole pas là pour exister
quelque chose qui vous lie à la
communauté juive à moi c'est rabbi jacob
j'ai dormi comme un bébé comme avec moi
je vous rappeler que nous sommes dans un
pays de culture chrétienne judéo
chrétien alors chrétienne les rois de
france n'était pas juste ça c'est
dommage a pas ce que vaut mieux avoir
l'avis de couper plutôt que la tête
c'est mal cette scène est coupée j'ai
fait les plus beaux gland nous toutes
les hauts-de-seine je sais pas d'épater
s'ils finissent à je suis pas je suis
écouté il arbore la fois
[Applaudissements]
tu peux me dire à quoi ça sert d'être
des vedettes on doit rester bloqué à
l'hôtel comme des cons jean paul lasne
homme d'église et c'est avec ce boys
band que vous comptez combler nos
actionnaires que c'est jésus a dit un
jour je m'en fous de ce qu'il a dit
c'est terminé salam shalom au revoir nos
cerveaux voir si ça casse toi un peu la
pression pour la casser l'ambiance et
qui c'est qui va la remettre ses tontons
sa vie
[Musique]